hello the Internet yes yes on to the
[Music]
situation it was at this point
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
delicious babies wait
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
well that was different for sure I mean
it's about time we got a new channel
trailer to be there it's true the old
one was first about three years old need
modernizing we've officially been sulla
fide by the Gregory Brothers just like
we've now officially had a slow-mo
schmoyoho collaboration that is a
mouthful I'm glad you had to say that to
be fair yeah well if you fancy listening
to that in your own time and your own
six foot balloon outside like I do you
can find it in a link down here
somewhere in the description yeah iTunes
link below and go subscribe to schmoyoho
and us if this is the first video you've
seen from us be sure to watch all the
videos that you saw in that remix mashup
flip it miss me and I promise you that
will be the last time we ever sing on
this channel never sounded that good
before imagine if this is the first
video someone sees was be about yeah I
should also we do slow-mo stuff as well
by the way just mainly yeah main it
mainly slow mister we will resume
regular content in the next video thanks
for watching